comme ultime étant maison
[Musique]
oui
ça fait un an que mon fils est décédé on
axe toujours passé faire elle peut pas
le faire le deuil
donc mon personnage est je tiens à faire
cet hommage là pour montrer aux jeunes
que l'on peut pas jouer tout le temps
par la violence fait et j'espère qu'au
moins que ça va c'est un petit peu de
même que aventure il ya encore un meutre
content que j'aimerais que ça cesse en
fait il faut montrer aux jeunes que ça
ne tient à rien donné un cri d'alerté en
fait j'espère que ça va aboutir un petit
peu mais c'est vrai que ça donne les
meilleurs je pense qu'ils font un petit
coup de pouce de la part de ge est passé
si l'état aux gouttes mais voilà donc je
tiens juste j'ai tenu à faire cette
image là mon fils